one last photograph many coal miners
remained true to traditions even as the
decade saw dramatic changes in the
industry at a miners Association event
in November they set a final farewell to
the community where the industry has
always played a central role it was a
moving moment it really hits you hard to
realize that it's all coming to an end a
lot of the guys have tears in their eyes
right now you know in the heyday of coal
mining there were 163 pits in Germany
pit manager Jurgen coca closed two of
them post by hanyul is his third and
last the other day when I was down the
shaft I thought this is probably the
last time you'll be down here with the
crew the last time you'll come down to
the coal face the world has really moved
on miners will continue to descend the
1,200 meters into the Earth's bowels
here until the end of next year but
instead of coal they'll be bringing up
machines cables and old iron most of the
equipment will end up in Turkey or China
many of the miners are bitter that their
machines are being sold off to
competitors who will end up supplying
Germany with cheap imported coal
mushiya Gerardus is the only miner in
the German parliament the Bundestag he
worked in the Batak mine for decades and
believes Germany's move to end the
industry is a big mistake we're going to
miss German coal one day the fact that
we're no longer producing it in Germany
doesn't mean coal-fired power generation
will cease so we'll need coal from other
countries and their prices will clearly
rise and the standards that we
introduced here don't exist in those
countries the landscape is still marked
by winding towers and coking plans but
other companies also moved in here long
ago but WAP is betting that by
developing something new on the many
areas once dominated by mining it'll be
able to secure jobs for the future
with deviates I'm optimistic because we
have good projects to develop further
areas first we'll clean up contaminated
old mining sites and then we'll help new
companies to set up here it's a big
project in the optimist issue Europe's
largest chamber of horrors has set up
shop in the old pits historically listed
laundromat a positive investment in the
region in the post-cold age